هل اصبح حلم ابطا شيخوخه او الحفاظ على
شباب دائم ممكن
ربما يكون فريق البروفيسور ديفيد سيكلر
عالم الجينات في كليه الطب جامعه هارت
اقترب من تحقيق هذا الحلم لكن كيف وصل الى
هذه المرحله المتقدمه
13 عاما من التجارب المتوسطه افضت الى
نتائج مثمره
العلماء من الوصول الى مرحله الرئيسيه في
تعلم كيفيه عكس مسار الشيخوخه قام فريق
الكره
بمحاكاه تاثيرات الشيخوخه على نوع اخر من
الخارج عن طريق ادخال فواصل في الحمض
النووي للفئران الصغيره ووجدت انه لا يمكن
للفئران ان تشيخ وفقا لجدول زملا متسارع
ولكن يمكنهم ايضا عكس اثار تلك شيخوخه
واستعاره بعض العلامات البيولوجيا لنضج
الحيوانات
هذه القابليه للانعكاس تقدم حجه قويه على
ان دوافع الرئيسيه لشيخوخه ليست طفرات في
الحمض النووي وانما اخطا في اشارات
الوراثه غير الجينيه التي تنحرف بطريقه ما
ويستثمار
عن وصفه في طريقها نحو الاضمحلال وانه مع
كل طفره نكون قد خسرنا رمز الحمض النووي
كامله غير اننا بيتنا نعرف الان ان
الخلايا تحافظ على الحمض النووي من دون ان
يتاثر ولا يتعين علينا سواء ان نعلمها كيف
تقرا ذلك الرمز مجددا
قد يعني ذلك ان مجموعه من الامراض بما في
ذلك الحالات المزمنه كامراض القلب وحتى
مرض الزهايمر يمكن علاجها الى حد كبير عن
طريق عكس عمليه شيخوخه التي تؤدي الى حدوث
هذه الامراض وتعد هذه الدراسه براي
العلماء مجرد خطوه الاولى لاعاده تعريف ما
تعنيه الشيخوخه وهم يرون ان كبار السن هم
اشخاص يحتاج نظامهم الى اعاده التشغيل فقط
لياك سما صار الشيخوخه لديهم